we interviewed a gentleman by the name
of Adam life's sake and he said that
most indie movie titles are horrible but
yours is very attention-grabbing but
there's no doubt about that and some
people might say horrible well how did
you come up with the title of a big
night and why did you end up sticking
with that as the shirt well I mean if
you know the movie was untitled or was i
working title um I should say you know
not untitled during the production was
called Tucson comedy horror which was
just to describe exactly kind of what
the movie was and you know we knew you
know we were searching during production
even if you know what was the title cuz
I didn't I didn't have any thing in my
back pocket ago I think this was what it
might be and just didn't want to title
that it was really searching it out it
was you know just like brainstorming
sessions throughout production with the
cast and crew that a few titles are to
jump out and dick night was one of these
that most people thought it was a joke
you know and it became a bit of a joke
for the for the cast and crew but you
know for me I always knew whom well that
Ben's probably the title to beat and you
know we did try to beat it with a lot of
other titles but it just kind of you
know still had its own life but there
was also a lot of questions of yeah we
you know cutting off or all right you
know is everybody just going to think
we've made a porn you know is probably
the stereotypical thing or or that it's
just kind of like a team TNA movie and
so you know there's up you know there's
good and bad with it that yet people
will probably remember it but you know
ultimately yeah the movies about a girl
trying to get laid on this one
particular night so it fit what feedback
have you received from audience members
about the title of any I mean it's the
same do you know with some people love
it and some people hate it you know it's
it's not one that people seem to be
middle of the road about you know
you